he is a Super Bowl champion from the
Green Bay Packers season of Super Bowl
45 he is also one of our favorites at
NFL Network he is James Jones how are
you James I'm good so the Packer season
here lies the 2019 Packers what what uh
what do you say about about this team
you know the goal is to win the Super
Bowls every year well when you just look
back on it and you see a rookie head
coach first time brought in the new
offense you know and you look about on
again all the good things that came out
of this season I mean defense play play
their tails off for me not last game but
all the season they play their tails off
very good teachers and build around you
got everything you want to build around
on the offensive end with analyzers
young running back in air and gel a
big-time receiver Devante have them so
the good thing is they got a taste of it
you know not Aaron Rodgers but he's been
evident age doesn't but you know man the
floor got a taste of his first time as a
head close to being the NFC Championship
but I think about the positives
you know coming out of the season but at
the end of the day I mean oh there goes
to win the Super Bowl and they fell
short so I know they don't think about
this before a long time so what happened
in the NFC Championship game James best
of your knowledge and your analysis here
what happened to this team watching
people all time rich if you cannot stop
the run you have no chance of being the
San Francisco 49ers I mean they have a
big-time defense we all know they can
rush more people drop seven still be
able to get pressure on the quarterback
down that's every deeper the
coordinators dream to be able to have a
business like that where you could drop
seven don't even have to pull it and you
guys and you still get pressures
consistently every down but when you
cannot stop the run and you continue to
beat up the clock and you run the ball
up and down the field I mean and 180
yards rushing in the first half and the
passes are in a run decent and we still
could not stop the run and if you're
able to do that I mean there you have no
chance I mean and we all know area rods
and special davontea special but
they were called company or 40 and when
the Niners are limited in the
possessions as well and running the ball
and finishing with touchdowns I mean
they're gonna be tough to beat James
Jones NFL Network and Super Bowl
champion with the Packers right here on
the Rich Eisen show in the Honda inside
a report I'm gonna bounce off some if
you will I wouldn't say it's
conventional but I don't know how wise
the conventional wisdom is here but
there's some statements that I want to
throw out there that have been thrown
out there about the Packers and
certainly after the NFC Championship
game and I want to see if you agree or
disagree with them the first one I guess
to react to is that Mike Patton and the
defense the way that they got gashed by
San Francisco requires a change on that
side of the football your thoughts
overreacting off in one game because if
you look at what the defense did this
year they played their tails off men and
they're truly the reason why the Packers
really had the record they have because
the offense was up and down all season
and the decent kept in their ball games
where there's more turnovers with sack
and things like that and I feel like
they played their tails off I feel like
if you add a couple other pieces to put
people you know another big-time
linebacker you know some some more speed
you know on the deeper side of the ball
I feel like it was the right guy for the
job and can get it done I mean obviously
I mean go out there this past weekend
and you know you get the ball read down
your throat but if you look over the
course of the season and these ones
really played well and have the Packers
in a lot of games so I really wanted to
see them make that change of how well
because of just how well the defense
played all year all right here's another
one for you that the coach in his first
NFC championship game as a head coach
and a play caller Matt Lafleur focused
on the wrong wrong Aaron that it should
have been more Jones than Rodgers in
Santa Clara what do you think about that
one James I think he going to the game a
curse they miss each other again you put
the ball in the best players hands and
that's Aaron Rodgers and you know it's
tough you know when - Daniel you can't
stop
you didn't limited possessions and the
Niners you know get a couple three and
outlawed your stuff but last time they
were out there make stuff run they got
after you know the offense so I believe
coming into this game and the right game
plan I mean getting there outside the
pocket early in the game let me make
some throws but you know the turnovers
Chilton you know what you're not telling
me in game plan okay we're going to run
this ball down the sentences so 49ers
throw where they are Jones so I believe
they have the right game plan put it in
your best players hands and get credit
to the Niners they got after the factors
in there Rodgers and you know false
turnovers and you know did what they get
all season and then the the other one
also is that it's it's time to start
thinking about the succession plan in
Green Bay at quarterback James I know
you are very partial to Aaron and that
makes complete sense and I take a look
at what Brady's been doing and what
Brees has been doing in their early 40s
and to me that just doesn't seem any
diminishing skillset on the part of
Aaron Rodgers but that has been out
there and that was out there in
Wisconsin going into the game too a
little bit
I wonder what you think well yeah five
more years left in and that high level
to play this game I mean when I go and I
watching that practice and when I watch
them in the games I mean he's still
making a lot of the special throws and
he was making when he was 22 so he's
this team's quarterback for the next
five years in my humble opinion but yes
I mean just like they did with their
Rodgers and Brett Favre you want to have
that guy behind Aaron Rodgers and when
he does hang a month to have that easy
transition to be able to have that guy
to learn from Aaron that was underneath
Aaron for a couple years and then he
came in there was another smooth
transition just like it was from breath
to air and hopefully it'll be some air
and somebody else but yes I feel like it
looks like going out there that you want
and you need any to learn from under air
Rodgers for the next next couple years I
mean yeah that would be a smart no how
would you address them the Packer fan
that's hearing you right now James Jones
and say you know what yeah we won 13
games but we were so not even close
to beating the defending NFC champion
xed year twice I mean it was it was a
dreadful situation and and and and just
running it back with a similar plan just
might not work so what what's the fix if
you will here for a team that finished a
distant second in the NFC this year the
performance will be getting another
big-time receiver on the other side of
the Pontiac
you know and and a lot of people always
say you know how special Aaron was but
if you really talk to err and Aaron Hill
givin you give us a lot of credit of how
special we were at the water receiver
position when we were all there myself
Donald Driver Jordy Nelson's and Michael
family Randall Kyle I mean a lot of
weapons to throw through and now when
you look around
Davante Adams and then you go to bizarre
as obvious the other players that you
know he's still trying to find a way to
build chemistry with and give
opportunities to like that and it's hard
so I would first start off I feel like
the defense is in a very good situation
you can add a couple more pieces in the
draft but if I'm the Packers in free
agency or my first ticket and I want to
go get another big-time wide receiver on
the other time in the Ponte back to fly
I can make big plays and then I feel
like that all fits right there with the
pieces around with Erik Jones Davante
Adams another big-time wide receiver
that's a really take a step to the next
level and I feel like that will make
their team much better just adding that
one piece over there and then get some
pieces I'm creating pieces later on in
draft and help that because I feel like
the Packers are in a very good situation
but let's start there you've got to have
more playing playmakers on the offensive
side of the ball especially just and who
would you say is was the MVP of the team
in 2019 because I truly believe Aaron
Jones made it easier on Aaron Rodgers
this year to again and was a Tulsa 500
yards a game but I mean he still is
making throws to win the game but
Aaron's made it easy on basically that
whole office I mean he was running the
they put them in path day I mean he had
an unbelievably hearing it's hard to to
go away from the guy who had 19
touchdowns and did it in the run game
and the prayer update so I will take
Aaron Jones James thanks for the time
great work again with the network this
year well let's chat real soon because
uh there as you pointed out Packers need
a receiver and this is according to
Daniel Jeremiah the richest receiver
draft he's ever had or covered
so let's chat soon
James thanks a call right back atcha
James Jones at 89 Jones NT AF for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app